I love quotes especially obscure quotes
and over the years I've collected some
of my favorites that you might not be
aware of for a little bit of segments
that we call quotables I said I said a
little bit of segments you don't see
that on other shows a little bit of
segment we call quarters uh here's his
first quote it's uh I'm walking here I'm
walking that is a first steps of ENSO
the Brooklyn toddler there is Oh get the
camcorder this only happens once hoagie
dumb quote oh look an old man with a
white beard so this is where we go when
we die
that one is a chicken who just wandered
into KFC crow hey I tried it Sam it's
garbage that one is an alternate ending
to dr. Seuss's green eggs and ham
stop pushing on me I'm my own
person you took me all these locales
your boat the Train I like cereal well I
had the craziest dream last night that's
someone I just stopped listening to
that's problems everybody